it goes back to like we always needed
men to protect us so if a guy's
aggressive he would have been able to
protect us back in the day
so there's like there's something
biological there you don't you don't
just just because we're in a more modern
society you don't get rid of our
biological Roots
but do you think that was very sad
though yeah you think it's sad yeah I do
think it's that and like also like I
should to be totally honest I was part
of a demographic of women that when I
was younger I thought that I was
supposed to want those things and it was
until I got a little bit older that I
was like oh I like don't have to have
violent sex like I can just say why did
you think you were supposed to want it
because of corn because of all the corn
that I'd seen in my life I thought like
women are supposed to have those
documents like violence really yeah I
remember seeing like a form of
documentary with parents coming out
about corn saying that what is exposed
on the internet they're scared for their
kids to grow up and see because they
couldn't they would never want their
kids to experience yeah and it's almost
like it's pushed you to think that is
okay for a man to do that or if that is
okay to do that without asking a
question and I think that's the
borderline of men as well I think it's
hard with men and women because I mean
obviously I've got two brothers and you
know I have cousins and stuff and I I
always say like sometimes actually just
let a woman show that she wants you so
there's no there's no question of you
didn't ask or I don't know if I was
emotionally ready and I'll say where I
say we're quite more emotional we've met
like than men so I feel like sometimes
we might think we want something until
it happens and sometimes when you're
taking more baby steps in a process we
have more time to back out and I think
if you're not given that time or a man
doesn't allow you to have that emotional
moment sometimes the lines can be
blurred and I think women that don't
want to take accountability for saying
no to things or to maybe be a bit more
open about things then push that
um anger or like regret feeling onto the
man which then turns into grape do you
see what I mean and I think there's a
finite they regret the sex that they had
or whatever they did and then they turn
it into great 100 and I think that you
know
how can I put it like they do that
because they don't like the fact that
they're angry at themselves and I guess
we they're not taking accountability for
that and it goes back to society where
women are pushed to kind of be in that
bubble of being okay with not doing that
and it is wrong I mean did you hear that
case in the U.S there was a guy who um
the girl accused him of grape and then
there there was footage that came out of
her pulling him back to the dorm and her
pulling him in to kiss her and he still
got kicked out of school
wow this is the way that the world's
going and it's scary and that's going
back to your point that's why I can
understand why people don't even want to
have kids anymore because then this is
the reason why as well men feel like
they can't even speak about things
because when they do you're misogynistic
you're controlling patriarchy all of
these buzzwords and yeah men don't feel
like they could even say at their own
Point yeah anymore without being looked
at a certain way I do think that when
you talk about like false great
accusations
to throw out the other side of that it's
just it's such a small issue and I
understand that when it does happen to
somebody it totally ruins their life and
that Minority of people like they are
ruined they get kicked out of University
they lose all their friends it is awful
but it's such a minority when you look
at like great cases in general how many
actually go to trial and then how many
actually like the person goes to prison
over it but it's just it's so hard to
prove especially if your partner does it
to you there's no proof you can't prove
it but that also in between go into
trial in between actually
was it innocent until proven guilty it's
actually you're guilty until proven
innocent well you have the court of
public opinion yeah I totally agree with
you but I just think that that's such a
minority I don't know any woman that's
accused a man of grape do you yeah
really I know someone that that's
happened to what if he's a school
teacher what if he's a school teacher
you know this world is so small all it
takes is for the wrong person to hear
the wrong thing and it can ruin someone
and he'll be suspended with full pay for
a period of time it's not as small as
issue as you think I hear what you're
saying like how many like actually make
it to court but then you've got to
remember that social media is everything
now and you gotta remember as well with
women that have experienced that or
they've got a friend that's experience
that or women kind of you know their
group thinkers in a way like they will
all you know jump in the mountain if
they feel like a woman's being abused
quite rightly but in certain circles if
it's a false allegation that guy's life
is ruined his reputation is ruined just
by someone saying
I'm just curious
who here knows someone that was falsely
accused of grape or assault or something
that you personally know and you believe
was false
so two three so this is one two three
four five six seven so out of seven
people that I don't know there's three
you don't think that's a big problem
massive problem massive I think that's
really hard though because I don't know
the people that you know I don't know if
you like if somebody accused somebody I
was very very close to of grape somebody
accused my brother there was nothing in
me that would ever think that my brother
would do that does that mean that I know
a hundred percent no you never know you
know anything though that's that's like
saying people that are exactly on death
row you know there's a lot of people
that have been sentenced to things they
should never ever they have been to
court and they've been dealt with by a
judge these are people that often
haven't I'm guessing most of these
things have sometimes been dealt with by
a judge doesn't also mean that it's fair
and it has it actually half the time
isn't right but it's based on evidence
but we just went over that it's not in
family corn and I I talked to these men
like they've had their entire reputation
ruined like if one guy even his whole
family thought that he did it like she
convinced him them that he did it
do you not think that that's odd though
if I was accused of something heinous I
think my family would believe I did it
and because I didn't you know no because
I think a lot of times when women cry
people believe them
um I think that if she really that
really happened to her I think she would
have went to court and I think you
should go to court that's a dangerous
mindset to have that there's a lot of
people that don't go to court for a lot
of reasons
um extremely traumatic thing well I I
think that you shouldn't be speaking
about something publicly that that a guy
has not had a chance to defend himself I
think that's not fair I I think if if
you're gonna accuse me of a crime and go
around saying that I committed a crime I
should have the right to go to court and
defend myself but the problem is women
will accuse men of things ruin their
jobs ruin their reputation and it's all
it's all from family court or the court
of public opinion neither of which that
he gets a fair trial but then he can do
what joined up did and defamation too
like I think I think you make it you
know and you're right Johnny Depp was
able to do that but you even a man with
money status and fame she still ruined
his life for a couple years what what
happens to the average guy the average
guy can't afford to do that yeah you
know expensive it is and I know because
I'm I'm
there's some people some of y'all can
get it
um
but I know it I know because like I'm
going to court with certain people so
it's like it's like it's expensive so if
a guy's making 40 000 a year and his
ex-wife just financed he's now homeless
what he's going to go to court to defend
himself how and remember everyone lacks
the pointer finger men or women it's
just human nature no one likes to take
responsibility for actions it's just the
natural thing to do right yeah but the
difference is that women can get away
with it where men can't because there's
no consequence so if there's a shitty if
both genders are shitty but the women
can get away with it what what are the
Men supposed to do well can I ask a
question I know we did the question do
we know anyone that's been accused of do
we can we do the same thing do we know
or know someone that was graped yeah go
ahead
yeah I just wanted to know in the room
yeah
I don't know I have a question did you
did you automatically believe them
yeah yes yeah I did but I I think that's
part of the did they go to court yeah
they were too young to go to court you
know I think well great can happen at
any time in your life right so I think I
actually do think that's like how I I
agree with you like I think when they're
younger they usually don't yeah and I
think sometimes you're actually so young
well it kind of turns into a different
type of um category of grape but I think
you're too young to even understand what
is actually even happening to you know
make that decision and agree yeah but
then I do sometimes I think when you
hear things as you grow up and you
people don't come out of things for 30
years and sometimes people have even
passed and whatever by the time you know
about something it's like with the
people around them when you said why was
it not spoken about because I mean I
can't sit here I've never gone through
something like that but there was a time
when I think I was about 11 years old
um my mum used to like she loves taking
us to pantomime it's really cool so we
used to go to pan tonight every
Christmas and one year I'll be back to
pantomime we went to Nando's after it
was like me my sister her partner's
brother and stuff and my brother and
then I just took like me my
brother-in-law and my brother down like
to the toilet I made sure they like I
didn't go in the toilet but I made sure
they locked themselves together in the
toilet and then I went to the toilet and
the guy that was in the toilet when I
watched them go in followed me out
followed me into the women's toilet and
as God is my witness I'm a good fearing
woman
there was 12 girls in there getting
ready to go on a night out doing their
makeup and I said thank the Lord I for
Rose I didn't know what I was gonna do
but I knew I'd do something in the end
but like in that moment I do understand
sometimes why women don't come out of it
straight away because I could never
imagine what would have happened if them
12 girls weren't in the toilet but again
at that age the first thing I did was go
to my mom yeah that was gonna be my
question because if they're younger like
why didn't they go to their parents yeah
because I went straight to my mom my mom
was ready you know I ain't gonna say
nothing on this but like you know my mom
was ready to rock someone bro you know I
mean like she was like Wasco like she
even went to the girls and asked did you
see that and they said we saw because
they answered me a UK and I said I'm
fine and then I just didn't even bother
going toilet I just grabbed my brother
and stuff and ran upstairs to my mom as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible